- This is, like, a "Hello,
Clarice" kind of situation.
(upbeat techno music)
- Today I am trying a
face mask from the 1990s.
- I feel like a face mask from 1999
would be like that slime from Nickelodeon,
maybe that's because like that's what I
would have wanted from
a face mask in 1999.
- I'm nervous because I feel like
it's going to be super extra and
I'm excited because it's going
to be super extra.
- Let's see what this thing is.
I'm kind of nervous. I'm going to be
like, slime from the ceiling or something.
(string horror music)
(record scratches)
(bell dings)
- I have, stop, I'm over it, I cannot.
- Oh my god, this is so scary.
- Ya'll, this looks like I'm about to
like, like I'm about to go rob something.
- Fun fact, Jason was based
off of this skincare product.
- Linda has on a full face of make-up.
Linda's face is beat, like, get into this.
- Obviously, talk about the complexion.
I guess this is supposed to look natural,
which is even scarier, but
this is not my skin color.
- Oh my god!
Welcome to my cult.
- Okay, Linda looks pretty fly.
She has a little neck
scarf, the power blazer.
- I like the soft jazz in the background.
That's a nice touch.
- Mask should not be
uncomfortable and tight.
It's definitely both of those things.
- Could you imagine like waking up next to
somebody with this mask on? I would die.
- I'm putting the gel on the probes
I assume so I don't get electrocuted.
- Linda's skin is tight and right.
She has not one pore or fine line.
However, I don't know if she
got all of that from this mask.
- I feel like I might
have like a different
face when I take this off.
Whoa! Whoa!
(squealing)
- Oh my god, you guys, this
is too much. What the f***?
- It's like, doo-doot-doo-doot-doo-doot
but on my face.
- Now it feels like they're stabbing me
with very tiny, little spears.
- Ahhh, I'm a monster.
- Oh, girl! Ooh, what is her name, Lisa!
Lisa, you are a liar. This is a scam!
- Linda, me and you have a problem.
- I'm glad that I tried it.
I won't be trying it again.
- I feel like Linda is like that friend
that's like, "Yeah, you look great!"
And then you go out and take all these
pictures and you see yourself like
on Facebook two years later and
you really looked a mess and
you're like, "Linda-Low-Key set me up."
- This mask, who knows,
it might be worth it
but all the time it takes to put the
little gel on the dots,
and ugh, it's not for me.
- Shouts out to Linda,
I respect the hustle.
It obviously works for her because she
looks amazing, but I'll be sticking
to my two dollar sheet mask.
- If anything, like, the nineties
skincare just proved that, like
every generation has its weird thing
that doesn't really
make sense for skincare
but they try it because humans are
absurd and are always grasping at youth.
I'll be curious in, like, ten years what
I'll think of the skin care fads now.
(upbeat music)
- What the? Ohhhh. Damn,
don't fool me like that, man.
Dang! Girl, you almost got (mumbles).
(upbeat saxophone music)